smiles here with Zeke CP3 J crossover
you're watching Center Court hope you
enjoyed the first game we had between
the Warriors and the Pelicans look it
was a two-point game at the half and
then Steph Curry was like okay time to
take this one over and from there they
outscored the Pelicans by 18 and a third
and the game was over and the game was
over um Steph Curry's ability to knock
down threes and knock down shots it
never gets old because it keeps the
defense on their toes but then he makes
plays like that where he's able to
finish around the rim in the first half
he opened up the Game knocking down
three quick threes the second half he
went into his bag as Jamal likes to say
wow he went into his Arsenal and this is
a guy taking these type of shots
shooting 15 for 22 from the field just
efficient and then now he has a guy in
Chris Paul that when he's off the floor
the ship stays level mhm and so th this
Warrior team team is going to be fun to
watch if they can keep playing like this
you know there's something else we got
to get to here right and it's the fact
that Steph Curry is 35 years old yes
it's the second night of a backtack and
you were telling us about the latter
part of your career like the joy that
he's playing with yeah and seeing what
he's able to do it's like he's not
slowing down no he's not slowing down
and and I was saying to to you and and
to Candice uh and Jamal the again the
joy that he plays with and the genuine
excitement that he has you know and it's
not fake it's not like he's doing he's
he's truly enthused with some of the
shots that he's making wouldn't you be
if you were hitting shots like that
would you not be in yeah but to still be
doing it at his age like you know
they're I mean for a guy like Steph
Curry right there there no more big
mountains to climb you know there no
more big moments he's he's really done
it all in the sport and to see he guys
like LeBron James Durant you know to see
these guys still playing at a very high
level at the age that they're at and
still having the genuine enthusiasm and
excitement of like a 14 15 year old I
mean we we saw him make shots tonight
and he was just as happy with the shots
that he was making tonight as the ones
that he was making in Houston the other
night and again and it's not you know
it's not fake this I think he's just
like damn I made that all look at me
it's pretty cool one of the most
exciting players we've ever had in the
league make no doubt about it Zion
Williamson had a good first half 13
points just six points in the second
half Tom M the the Warriors really were
like okay this is a two-point game how
do we slow them down and it seems like
it started with stoen z and they have
Championship pedigree so they know when
a guy has it going or what they're going
to do to kind of slow him down things
were more difficult Draymond grabbing
his jersey right there Then looking like
where's the foul things like that play
on your mind and when you're Zion you
don't want to think as much you just
want to play you want to be free and the
Warriors will put you in that
predicament look where where draymond's
guarding him right now okay crowd the
paint make him pass the ball that's a
win for the Warriors when he doesn't
have ball the ball and and putting
pressure on your defense so they did
that in the second half and really
clamped down on them I think Zan get
better at it but going against a
championship team they can make those
adjustments